ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Hi.
Welcome back to DEVOXX 2013.
I'm here with Dan to
talk about a service
that Google is offering
to game developers.
So welcome, Dan.
DAN GALPIN: Thank you.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Tell
us what this is really about
and who we're
targeting with this.
DAN GALPIN: Sure.
Well, the service is
Google Play Game Services.
Developers have been
asking us for a long time
how to help them find users and
how to help them engage users
and, more importantly, how to
give them some features they've
been desperately wanting.
And so we put together
a service that
give users what they've been
wanting for a long time, which
is Cloud Save.
We have achievements
and leaderboards,
which drive engagement.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: OK.
DAN GALPIN: And what's really
exciting about this is we
haven't just done
this for Android,
but we've actually made this
a cross-platform solution.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Hence the name.
It's not the Android service.
It's the Google--
DAN GALPIN: Exactly.
It's a Google service.
And it's really important,
because we recognize
that people want to
play games with not just
their friends who
own Android devices.
But they want to be able to play
games with their iOS friends,
friends with other
devices, and, of course,
people who are using
the web and Chrome.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: OK.
Great.
So a lot of people can use this.
People have been using
other solutions before.
Here, we're offering
this as a service.
Obviously, it's
a Google service.
You would expect this to
scale, this to be always up.
And so how about sign in?
Is there any identity
integration offered with that?
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
We do use Google+ identity.
And that's really important,
because we wanted privacy
to be paramount from the
very start of this service.
And Google+ gives us the ability
to give the users the kind
of privacy controls
they expect from Google.
That's really important.
There was a lot of resistance
to a lot of different sign ins
that we were seeing.
And so we said, all right.
What do we need to
do in order to make
sure we get as many people
as comfortable with signing
in and sharing their game
activity with the people
they want to share
it with as possible?
So it really was a no-brainer
for us to look at Google+
identity.
ALEXIS
MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: So you
are one of the people that
looks after developers
that build games.
How has this been going so far?
DAN GALPIN: There's a huge
amount of excitement for it.
Again, users have been really
wanting this for a long time.
And people have
actually been asking me,
whether it's been developers,
whether it's been gamers,
they've been coming up
to me and saying, please,
please do something
in this space.
And I think what's exciting is
we didn't just do something,
but we're really doing something
with a very broad reach.
We could have done something
very, very simple, I think.
And instead, we
chose to really go in
with a tremendous service.
And what's exciting to me
is it's a Google service.
And game developers were really,
really worried in the past.
They would go, and
they would choose
a service that did
some of these things.
The company would cancel
it, or as it would scale,
it would start costing
them a lot of money.
And what's great is we're
providing this service
to game developers
for free across all
these different platforms.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
It's worth mentioning.
DAN GALPIN: And if
they're successful,
they don't end up losing
out, because the service is
going to scale with them.
It's not going to start
costing them money.
They can be comfortable that the
service is going to be around.
And that's exciting for me.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
One of the features
is multiplayer games.
DAN GALPIN: Yes.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
How does that really work?
And is that realtime?
What kind of gaming really
can I build with that?
DAN GALPIN: I can't
believe I didn't even
mention that at the beginning.
Yeah.
One of the most
important features we do
is realtime multiplayer gaming.
And that allows a developer
to create a mesh network
with currently up to
three of their friends,
so a four-player mesh network.
And it's realtime gaming.
It's great because it
chooses the fastest
route it can between
the four players.
So if you're on a
local network, it
will actually choose a route
that will connect directly
between the players for really,
really high speed, low latency
gaming.
And it'll also ping our servers
and do nat traversal for you
if need to play a game
over the internet.
So it's really, really powerful.
And again, what's
great is in order
to do this without
Google scale, you
would have to have
machines and data
centers all around
the world in order
to try to get low
latency connections.
Google is just providing
this because we
want to make the gaming
experience great.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Awesome.
I've built a game.
I know how to build
games, say, on Android.
Let's take that example.
What does it take for
me to actually integrate
with that service?
And how hard is it to add
it to an existing game?
DAN GALPIN: That's one of
the things that's great.
It all depends on which
platform you're on, of course.
On Android, we've made it
part of Google Play Services.
So it's a part of things
that people have already
got on their device.
We're constantly
pushing updates to that,
constantly making
the platform better.
And all they have to do is
integrate a very, very simple
library that we've put together.
We have tons of
sample code for them,
including a bunch of great
little sample games that
illustrate all the
different features.
We actually did a Code
Lab here at DEVOXX
where we had people
integrate Google Play
Services with a game.
It took about 20
minutes for most of them
to get the basic
stuff all integrated.
And it's exciting.
It's exciting to see how
quickly people can move on it.
On iOS, we also provide
a client library.
And then for the web, it's
a series of REST APIs.
And those can be used anywhere,
of course, which is exciting.
It's not just focusing on
these two mobile platforms.
But we wanted to make sure the
experience for Android and iOS
developers was great.
It also allows us to provide a
lot of features to those users.
For Android and iOS
users, for example,
we support offline achievements,
offline leaderboards,
all of those kinds of offline
features that people expect.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
I was going
to get to the
offline part of it.
I commute.
I take the metro, and
connectivity's not always
there.
DAN GALPIN: Absolutely.
It is really important.
If someone gets an
achievement offline,
they want to see it
pop up in the service.
They want to see that
it's going to get back
to Google eventually.
And so we do.
If you get the
achievement offline,
on Android we'll go and sync it
in the background the next time
we get connectivity.
On iOS, we don't do that yet.
But the next time you play the
game and you have connectivity,
it'll make sure
to sync things up.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: OK.
Great.
What is the experience in terms
of the Google Play Developer
Console?
Do you get to see how people
use your game and the API?
DAN GALPIN: You get
a couple of things.
One is that you do get
some basic analytics
on how people are
using your game.
Obviously, I always recommend
people put their own analytics
in as well.
But as we roll this
out further, we're
going to have deeper and deeper
engagement numbers, which
is exciting.
What's also cool
is we actually get
to see the engagement
numbers as well.
And I think this is exciting.
Because we don't track
people's usage on Android,
so we don't know what
games they're playing.
But now they're signing in.
They're saying,
yes, Google, we want
you know about what we're doing.
And that gives us
a much better way
of actually directing people to
games that we know users love.
So it's not just a question of
have they downloaded the game,
but who's actually
playing, who's
actually engaging
with that content.
It allows us to be much smarter
in terms of Google Play.
And of course, we also have the
Google Play Games application.
That's great because
you can actually
go to this application.
We have, according to Google
Play, between 10 and 50
million downloads
of this already.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: OK.
DAN GALPIN: You can go and see
what your friends are playing,
and you can also see how
your friends are progressing.
So you can go leaderboards, and
that's huge for competition.
There are several games
I've played because I've
seen that one of my
friends was playing it,
and then I realized
that I have to beat
their scores on
the leaderboards.
ALEXIS
MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Right.
DAN GALPIN: I'm naturally
somewhat game competitive,
I guess.
I see it working
just within our team.
And I know it's working
out in the world as well.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Cool.
So where should developers
go to learn about this?
DAN GALPIN: They should go to
developers.google.com/games.
That'll take them to a page
talking all about the things
that we offer for
game developers.
And then if you go to
developers.google.com/games/services,
that actually has all of the
things we're doing with Google
Play Game Services.
But do go to the main Game site.
There's a lot of stuff we're
doing for game developers
out there.
I think that it's really
exciting to see Google getting
behind games the way we
have in the last year.
ALEXIS
MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Great.
Well, Dan, thanks.
This is all the
time we have for.
Try it out and provide feedback.
You guys are online available?
DAN GALPIN: Absolutely.
You can go, of course,
to the Android developer
channel for the Android APIs.
And of course, go to
developers.google.com
to learn more about
what we're doing
and to see our announcements
involving games.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Stack Overflow is a good place?
DAN GALPIN: Stack
Overflow is a great place
to ask questions, as always.
We have a team that goes and
monitors that as well as making
sure that we actually
integrate your feedback.
You can also actually give us
feedback on our GitHub site.
That's actually where we
post all the sample code.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Oh, good.
DAN GALPIN: And you
can also post changes.
If you have any ideas or bug
fixes that need to go there,
that's a great place to
talk with the team as well.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Cool.
Game on.
DAN GALPIN: Thank you.